and talk about your process because I
understand the title of the movie the
name of the movie is the first stop and
then you figure out the plot and figure
out the characters I mean if you look at
some of the movie names that you guys
have set up have produced in the past
it's pretty unbelievable mega Python
versus Gator oeid Bermuda tentacles 3
Headed Shark Attack
someone said sharknado and come up with
something right basically and thank you
for saying that our movies have plots
yeah we're very strong believers that
for our types of movies you should know
exactly what the movie is based on the
title alone ok so Paul what are you
expecting what's your expectation here
with tonight's premiere
I predict that we are going to break the
internet again I think that shark I
think that sharknado has become sort of
a collective event for the world even
though we're not all in the same room
watching it everybody is participating
through social media and having a great
time and I think that Wednesday night is
going to to be another big night for
sharknado
so modest I know well I you know I was I
was telling scarlet that I think I saw
the it was it was sharknado they
original the first one that was playing
on the channel it was a marathon in
anticipation of tonight you know and it
was very camp obviously you know the
Campina sub it and you know that's fun
to watch I mean have you have you spent
more money as each as each film has come
out or are your margins pretty you know
still pretty high with these films yeah
we definitely have spent more money as
the as the films have come out I'm happy
to say that the first two are profitable
I would love to be able to tell you that
relatively they had performed
financially as well as they've done in
social media but they haven't contrary
to what people believe my toilet is not
made out of solid gold alright last
question very quickly Paul how far along
do you think blashyrkh dinner will go
sharknado 5 1012 well we're planning for
12 I've already got the ideas